welcome to the creation crystal bottle
master here you can create your very own
imaginator
let's choose a battle class each class
uses a unique type of weapon
social imaginaries channel the energy of
skylines weather in trenchant states are
you ready to create a sorcerer choosing
a battle class is a final decision a new
sorcerer is born now bring your
imagination to life what yeah what's
that
yeah
nice an exciting proposition
I am one graceful beware of behold the
unknown
behold falling rocks be home bill bill
the whole deal the whole be hope the
whole zombie dance parties behold zombie
dance party behold behold zombie did
behold
zombie dance parties
a whole zombie dent behold zombie dance
party behold behold zombie dance parties
behold behold behold my barbarian
magnetism
this is the imagine night vault as you
explore Skylands unopened imagine I'd
chests will be sent here these chests
will reward you with new creation
possibilities you can add more chests if
you wish why not try opening one now
bard found new let Bart found new years
set complete barbarian magnetism
Skylanders the stronger
sensei's are stronger here
well done Skylanders the musical vibe of
the islands is already a little less
chaotic spiral has scouted ahead for
more areas with bad vibes and heat as an
interesting theory he's waiting for you
in the village at the base of mop pump
up there in the distance go meet him and
keep your ear out for anything that
sounds you know that